hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in looking at the
fragments of the ontological or
metaphysical poem by Parmenides of Alea
that we do possess one of the key themes
it's very important for the history of
philosophy that arises is the inter
relation between thought and generally
that's expressed here in terms of
knowing the activity of thinking and
being a knight to be and and for
Parmenides these are actually going to
turn out to be the same and and I don't
think you can say the same thing because
that sounds as if there's many things
and these to happen to be the same thing
for Parmenides ontologically or
metaphysically there's only one there's
only it can you call it one thing
there's only one reality everything else
is false or non-being or you know a
becoming that is is also a lie so you
know there's some paradoxes that arise
in how though the poem is itself
articulated given that that's the case
but one of the the key ideas that he's
putting forward is what we call monism
this notion that at bottom or you know
ultimately everything is one reality
everything is the same thing and you
could say anything that doesn't fit into
that would actually not have any being
at all strictly speaking it should be
unimaginable or unsayable and he does
kind of hint at that at different points
but he also does contrast two different
paths and so the one path the true or
trustworthy path of being the one that
the goddess is revealing to him and
saying that mortals generally aren't on
this path because they think that there
really is becoming and there's motion
and change and multiplicity of things
the true path of being says that being
is non being is not and it asserts that
it's wrong to say that non being is it's
also wrong to say that being is not or
that something is not and that being
could change in any way that's there
later on in the poem so there's these
two paths that are laid out for him and
he's advised to use thought as a way of
judging between these two ways
ultimately of thinking or you know you
could say thinking well and thinking
poorly thinking the right way thinking
in ways that go astray right
and the ways that go astray rely on our
habits and our sense is pure thought is
what's required in order to fully
understand the option between the two
paths in front of him the path of being
the true path and the path of non-being
or becoming or illusion or or lies
however you want to put it so thought is
you could say the instrument or the the
ability that allows us to formulate this
problem in the first
place a problem of thinking and it's
also what gives us access to being
itself if we follow the right path
according to those again that Parmenides
has laid out so that's one way of
understanding the relationship between
thought and being right being in that
case would seem to be you know
ontological II prior it's it's there and
then here comes the thinking person and
while they can see being as such and you
know being would be just fine without
the thinker because being is and it's
not gonna like you know go out of
existence if there's no thinker that's
one way to look at it but Parmenides is
actually going further he's saying being
and thought are actually the same
they're not something different so this
implies that thought is not just
thinking being has sort of at a distance
from it thought is how being grasps
itself and so we are invited you know in
the poem to join in on this by
traversing the same path that Parmenides
lays out for himself in the mouth of
this goddess who could be the same thing
as just our minds as well so here we
want to think about a few key passages
that I have here in in Greek and I'll
tell you the Greek and then we'll talk
about some possible translations of it
so thought as being itself in fragment 3
which is very short
he says toga Otto know Ain esteem 2 chi
ni sono Ain is the the infinitive for
think right to to think or the act of
thinking and ni is being that's the verb
for to be to to actually exist to to
have being and the sum of these things
like Takei and and dot or those are
these sort of particle words God or
means
thing like so therefore or you know hey
look at this and you know Kai means and
so togehter Alto for it's the same Auto
means the same toe out oh the same thing
so you know look here this is the same
thing what's the same thing these two
things that are connected by the the
verb here s Dean s T is the same verb as
ni and they both refer to being alright
so being is actually showing us that
thinking and being in the infinitive are
the same thing
you could you could translate it as four
it is the same thing to think and to be
or you could translate it and more
generally thinking and being are the
same right or you could say are
identical or they're not different from
each other there's a lot of different
ways you could you could frame this but
what is it asserting their thinking and
being not different from each other
thinking is if it's real genuine
authentic thinking is showing us how
things are including about that very
same thinking right or you might say
turning it on the other side being to be
is to think so that being thinks itself
he goes on and he says that this is in
fragment for what can be said and what
I'm saying fragments I mean from the
deals fragmented for the for Socratic er
what can be said leg gain there's the
word to speak or to say and thought must
be so now he's not saying that
everything that we can say every verbal
formula we can come up with is therefore
existing as such you know like the
unicorn poked me in the eye with his
horn no unicorns right so I'm not
getting poked in the eye with a horn
just because I said it because the probe
is no here's what can be said and
thought what can true
maybe thought what can be thought
through is exists as being so a little
bit later in the long section which is
fragment 8 he will say two other things
about this connection between thought
and being and they're both actually in
the same you know section so he says how
tone destino aim to Chi hoon ik n SD no
mo
so we've got two different thought words
here no aim this activity of thinking
and then we have no way m'a that which
is thought right and so what is he
saying there again we have a tone it's
the same thing
2-out own right desti this is the same
thing what is the same thinking and no
Hoonah ken is a composite of two words
hennequin that on account of and then
hole here that on account of which there
is thinking or we can say that thought
and the object of thought are the same
thing what is the object of thought
being so thought and what is being
thought by thought
ie being those are the same thing this
is another way of framing it but it's
going a little bit more into precision
saying whatever it is that we are you
know taking in and thinking about that
is thought the activity of thought so
that's a nice way to translate it this
translation here has here we go
you want to find that section you yeah
you the same thing both can be thought
and is that which enables thinking right
that's a little bit more obscure
actually but but it's not a bad way of
thinking about it that which we can
think about
that's the enables there he follows up
by saying you gotta renetto Altos and
whole parry Pfau steamin on s teen he'll
race ace tono Wayne very fancy Greek
phrase there right so the the we could
actually turn it around and start here
pure ace ace and the Oh God right
ooh God for you will and you will not
discover your race this is the word that
we get heuristic from you will not
discover or find tone owain thinking you
will not find thinking without or not in
the presence of a now to a loom toasts
you will not find it outside of
something that has being Altos is is the
in here the participle right and whole
pantry FASTA Meno Nestene so this is
coming from the the verb to to to
articulate to speak write and hold pity
fosston men on has seen that in which we
can express something so it's translated
here as a little bit you know less
literally you will not find thinking
apart from what is on which it depends
for its expression
now what depends on what for its
expression in it kind of goes both ways
thought depends on what is in order to
articulate itself in order to say itself
but being also needs thought to express
it so there's this really interesting
complex relationship of two things that
are asserted to be the very same thing
thought and being in these sections in
Parmenides poem it's not so simple as to
just say well thought and being same
thing there is a matter of articulation
there's a matter of sort of
interdependence II there's a matter of
reflexivity that's involved there if we
sort of read between the lines and call
out what has to be the case in order for
this to really make sense so this is a
profound insight if it's actually true
by per minute ease in his poem the
identity or unity of thought and being
you